c'est du jamais vu
du jamais fait une odyssée dans l'espace
en réalité virtuelle vous êtes aux côtés
de david saint-jacques et vous voyez ce
qu'il voit autour de lui trois
dimensions sur 360 degrés c'est une
série en réalité virtuelle sur la vie
dans l'espace des astronautes contourne
pendant un an sur la station spatiale
on va aussi en faire le contenu d'une
exposition qui va se promener un peu
partout dans le monde
les astronautes se prépare à sortir pour
aller travailler à l'extérieur de la
station
aujourd'hui on est en plein tournage
l'équipe de felix épaules assiste en
direct à une sortie dans l'espace la
tension est palpable et les choses qu'on
contrôle ya des choses qu'on ne contrôle
pas quand tu fais un tournage un espace
le plateau de tournage et à 400 km de la
terre tourne autour data dans quai des
choses qui sont hors de notre contrôle
le but de l'opération tourné en réalité
virtuelle les préparatifs d'une sortie
de la station et se préparer pour la
prochaine étape
le tournage des astronautes avec une
caméra fixée sur le bras canadien
la série comptera six épisodes de 15 à
20 minutes
une première pour la nasa produite par
le magazine time et réalisé par le
studio montréalais félix épaules le
pionner mondiale dans le domaine
david saint-jacques rapidement endossé
le projet quand il était en mission
orbitale
il est devenu un allié précieux
wen
[Musique]
décembre 2018 une fusée de
ravitaillement s'envole vers la station
spatiale internationale
à son bord deux caméras originale mise
au point par une petite équipe de
l'entreprise montréalaise
la caméra est idéal pour filmer dans
l'espace il faut qu'elle soit faite il
faut qu'elle soit légère
et il faut que ça soit facile
d'utilisation donc le temps
d'astronautes dans l'espace c'est pas
infinie donc ça prend un système qui est
assez intuitif autant au niveau de
l'interface au niveau de l'utilisation
générale la caméra c'est la première
fois que des caméras de réalité
virtuelle sont envoyés dans l'espace
pour faire une production de ce niveau
là on est un peu en tant que spectateur
un astronaute ou un protagoniste de
l'histoire
je pense que pour les astronautes une
nouvelle manière de communiquer ce
qu'est la vie d'un astronaute sac et
l'exploration spatiale
impressionnant pour une petite compagnie
montréalaise gens c'est sur quelques
idées originales il ya six ans par félix
lajeunesse et paul raphaël de diplômés
en cinéma à l'université concordia
tout ce qu'on tourne tout la date heure
les données sont traitées ici par des
artistes qui font de la postproduction
se spécialise dans la stéréoscopie à 360
degrés il fallait tout inventé dans ce
monde inexploré de la réalité virtuelle
cinématographique on développe nos
outils nos logiciels
dans ce dessein utilisé pour créer des
oeuvres originales
félix et paul ont déjà été primé de
nombreuses fois aux emmy entre autres
pour plusieurs réalisations de réalité
virtuelle avec patrick watson gimnasia
cette année au festival tribeca et le
cirque du soleil également
le studio compte une soixantaine
d'employés venus pour certains d'un peu
partout dans le monde
les deux projets peut-être les plus
importants qu'on a fait c'est le projet
qu'on y retourne à la maison blanche
avec le président obama
donc en 2016 et ça nous a ouvert
beaucoup de portes et je pense notamment
les portes de l'espace donc les projets
qu'on a fait par la suite avec la nasa
et le projet qu'on est en train de faire
qui probablement le projet le plus
ambitieux du studio depuis qu'on a
commencé le tournage avec la nasa ouvre
à félix épaules perspectives sont
limitées
cette technologie l'on veut l'utiliser
pour documenter les prochaines étapes de
l'exploration spatiale qui vont arriver
dans les prochaines années
donc la mission lunaire éventuellement
mission vers mars
donc on peut faire partie de ça puis on
veut que la réalité virtuelle finalement
soit le médium pour documenter les
prochaines étapes de l'exploration
humaine de l'espace